for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university calm thank you and enjoy okay
so next up we've got the amino acids
degraded to sucks in Ocoee how many
amino acids have their carbon skeleton
degraded directly to sucks nail color
there are four of them okay one of them
is Matheny a second is threonine third
isoleucine and fourth valine so let's
check that out
alright so first things first is we'll
start with this methionine five carbons
we're gonna turn it into Sam s
adenosylmethionine using an ATP and the
methionine adeno sila transferase enzyme
and so we get Sam which we've seen
before as the primary methyl group donor
and notice that I have five carbons here
with this little asterisk that's
excluding the portion from the
nucleotide or the nucleus I'd write the
adenosine portion I'm not counting any
of these carbons on this thing because
that's eventually just gonna be just
gonna leave as we'll see soon so Sam is
a methyl group donor that's what's gonna
happen here it's gonna donate this
methyl group that pink carbon to some
species without a methyl group using
some methyl transferase enzyme and that
species will then have that methyl group
and so the other four carbons are going
to be here part of almost cysteine or s
edema so homocysteine and we're gonna
get that homocysteine by hydrolyzing off
that adenosine using a hydrolase and so
that identity and falls off and we get a
homocysteine okay this should all I kind
of rushed through that and the reason
why is because at this point I hope you
have seen the video on one carbon
transfer especially the one on Sam since
it's so it applies here okay so now we
have homeless cysteine for carbon amino
acid
and we're gonna add to that a serine a
3-carbon amino acid to get syste
theanine and that's going to be
catalyzed by sister thiamine beta
synthase so basically what happens is
that we're adding the serine portion to
this part of homeless cysteine so we get
it attached right here like this so this
is called sista thiamine okay that's
seven carbon molecule and then we're
going to get rid of this part as a
cysteine so it came in as a Syrian we're
going to fall off as a cysteine so we're
going to lose those three carbons again
and in that process that process is
going to be catalyzed by assigning gamma
lice and we'll also lose this amino
group we're gonna lose that amino group
and we will get alpha keto butyrate
which looks like this so this portion of
the molecule gives us the alpha keto
butyrate okay and we can get this alpha
keto butyrate also from from threonine
okay and this is actually the major
pathway by which threonine is degraded
and going from three alpha keto butyrate
we're going to remove the amino group as
well as the HOH as we're gonna lose that
water and that is gonna be catalyzed by
threonine dehydratase and we saw a
dehydrogenase enzyme before it was
serine do you had to chase this enzyme
acts in pretty much the same way in fact
it might even be the same enzyme so the
point is though that we end up with this
alpha keto butyrate which we can add a
coenzyme a to as well as we had this
coenzyme a to it and get rid of this
carboxyl group as a carbon dioxide and
we go
that four carbon molecule to a three
carbon propane yolka way okay now we get
that propane yoke away from isoleucine
and we've actually seen this before
except I'm switching up the coloration
of these carbons these two carbons as we
said before end up in acetyl co a after
adding this coenzyme a this carbon or in
the carboxyl group is going to leave as
a carbon dioxide and these three carbons
end up in the propane Eelco a we also
get some nadh and fadh2 is out of that
and of course that acetyl co a could be
oxidized now we could also get this
propane yoke away from valine we're
gonna remove the amino group just like
we did over here with the with the
isoleucine a transamination reaction
okay and this carbon up here and the
carboxyl groups gonna leave is a carbon
dioxide and this carbon right here is
going to leave as a carbon dioxide as
well so we're gonna be left with those
three orange carbons those three orange
carbons are going to give propane Yoko a
yes the point is that both of those
amino acids give propane Ocoee in fact
all of these amino acids their carbons
ended up in propane Yoko a and the
propane Yoko a we can carboxylate it
adding a carbon dioxide using ATP using
an enzyme catalyzed by an enzyme called
protein Ocoee carboxylase this requires
biotin before I go on I forgot to put
the name of the I mean the enzyme here
that acts on alpha keto butyrate that is
alpha-keto acid dehydrogenase okay
this propane yoko a is carboxylated by
propane yoko a carboxylase very cleverly
named here requires biotin as a coenzyme
or a cofactor of course this is a one
carbon transfer where the one carbon is
in its most oxidized form as co2 being
attached right here to give D methyl
Millenial Kawai
and this D methyl Melanie oh my Melanie
Oh a where this is basically just the
stereoisomer right and that is done by
methyl Melanie okay racy mace and that L
methylmalonyl coenzyme a Yoko a mutase
which moves this carboxyl group from
that carbon to this carbon to give get
that there to make succinylcholine and
co factor in that reaction is coenzyme
b12 which we've seen one other time and
the videos on one carbon transfers okay
so this is a second of two reactions
that in which coenzyme b12 is used okay
so that's how the amino acids are
degraded to succinylcholine I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying